Let's go to Isaac from Ohio.
Next, Isaac from Ohio, you're on the air.
Oh, God.
Hello, how are you?
Good.
What can I do for you, so forgive me if this
is completely incorrect, because he's not
taking a single economic class or anything,
but I know that you're you're like a social
Democrat.
You're not in favor of, like, full blown socialism.
Right.
But I came up with an idea a little while
back.
What if.
Instead of like outlawing like capitalism
to go to socialism, because that would be
too complicated, it's like I don't I don't
know what if we take.
What if we, like, defined like wage slavery
properly and outlawed that, like you couldn't
just like the common practice of just hiring
someone, paying them a flat rate for their
labor where they have no ownership of their
workplace, if we like, at least gave workers
some ownership of their workplace in all cases.
So you're saying that with some kind of some
kind of law that says every employee must
be given partial ownership of their place
of employment?
Yeah, I don't see how you get that done legally.
I mean, I don't I don't even know that it's
I think that the way to do it.
So that would be a very authoritarian imposition.
And check out my interview with the with the
YouTube or Vash, who is a socialist.
But he said that the way that as he sees it,
the way you're going to implement these things
is going to be by convincing businesses and
others that it's a good idea for them to do
it rather than imposing it as law, that I
hope I'm not wrong in summarizing his perspective
that way.
But even he said that the types of things
you're talking about are very authoritarian
and would essentially be dead ends.
And I think that he's probably right about
that.
I think what you're suggesting would be very
would essentially be impossible to do.
You would just be saying you would be mandating
you are trying to force companies to do things
that there's no legal basis to force them
to do.
It's less about economics, it's more about
the law.
OK, so you're not particularly against something
like that, you're just saying it's not realistically
possible.
So as a as a social Democrat, I'm not in favor
of what you're describing.
But for me, it's not even really the main
issue because it's just you're not going to
get it done in the way where there's just
a law passed and it says all employees are
now owners.
Yeah, well, I'm not trying to make it that
simple, like what if if we say like the lowest
tier of workers have to own, like, at least
20 percent of the entire company collectively,
is that something that could work or.
I don't see I don't see how you get it passed.
I mean, I think the more important thing would
be to for you to think about this less as
an economic thing.
But more is a how do you how do you get what
is the legal structure where you could do
that?
Where government could do that?
Is it federal and is it state?
And if it's one versus the other, how do you
actually do it?
And I just don't see it.
I think if I were you, I would focus on how
you get it done rather than whether it's a
good idea.
I just don't see how you how you ever get
that done.
Oh, yeah, I see, that's a really good point,
no.
All right, my friend, though, I appreciate
the call.
Yeah, thank you.
All right, pleasure.
Let's take a couple of others, because there
are many people, many, many people who want
to chat.